all right let's keep on going another
couple of relatively straight forward
questions so you can see in question
four the difference here or the the
thing that stands out about it is unlike
previous questions where we were always
doing it as a an area by addition so we
were looking at the different components
say for example
um a triangle plus a rectangle plus a
triangle in this case it's much easier
to consider this as a large Square
ah I'm actually moving the whole thing
that's hilarious let's try that again
just put it back where it belongs there
we go
um maybe I'll just delete it and you can
see what I started with in the first
place that's the whole big thing it's a
square with the two corners cut off
right and you just need to work out
what's the size of those Corners so if I
put that back you can see I did that
purple diagram there to be able to work
out what is the thing I need to subtract
so you can see that's double times base
times height squared it just happens
it's another isosceles triangle on there
so that's why the base and the height
are both three so that gives you that
calculation to do the perimeter
um you've got it there's no shortcuts
around this one so you've got one two
three four lengths that are all equal to
the 15 kilometers so that's where this
comes from and then you can recognize
I've done Pythagoras again the two comes
from the fact that there's one
hypotenuse here and it's the same
hypotenuse on the other side
okay question five this uh boneless
looking shape here to work out the area
uh again we've got to identify what the
figures are there's a triangle right
there in the middle and then you've got
three semi-circles on the outside so
that's why you can see um I've gone what
is A1 that's a semicircle so I just did
half of pi r squared gave me this
what's a two again I used Pythagoras to
work out uh in this case actually this
is a bit sneaky I think I've just done
I've just spotted an error for myself
which is always handy it's always better
to spot narrow let's actually fix it
here you're using Pythagoras but you're
not finding a hypotenuse you're actually
finding a shorter side trapped for young
players trap for all players too so in
this case if we just do it long hand
right what you can see here
is the H squared plus 2 squared equals 4
squared because 4 squared is the 4 is
the hypotenuse so what I've got really
is that H squared equals that 16 take
away 4 that's where I've subtracted 4
from both sides so H is going to be the
square root of 12 which is not what I
had before as you can see here so let's
fix that
this is the square root of 12.
now let's see here the square root of 12
I can take out a factor of the square
root of 4 so that would give me uh that
that took out before but instead of 4
root 5 I should have tweaked before that
5 wasn't the right number that should be
a 4 root 3 which of course carries on to
here so let's
correct that answer shall we six pi plus
four root three there we go all right I
was in the ballpark which is why my
sense check didn't pick up the fact that
it was incorrect but it's 25
[Applause]
.78 when you round to two decimal places
square meters there you go no one's ever
uh Beyond checking their own answers and
finding a mistake let's have a look at
the perimeter and let's double check it
shall we so you've got uh this one is
simpler so all you've got here is three
uh half circumferences right so that's
why it's three times half times pi times
the diameter because that there is the
definition of circumference we halve it
to get the semicircle and then you've
got three of them so thankfully that
one's not too complicated
okay now the last one here question six
this is the last one which has a bit of
a curveball in it so for this one it
looks a bit like you you can't possibly
have enough information supplied to you
to solve this question right um all
you've got is these these curvy bits and
then you've got a 25 millimeter length
there I've just labeled these a b and c
because I'm about to work with them
right
how are we going to be able to take this
small amount of information that's
available and then deduce from that use
reasoning and logic to work out what
kinds of shapes you're dealing with and
and what's actually composed what
figures have been composed together
well the first thing you need to realize
is that and again you'll be forgiven for
not really recognizing this because
um I talked this through with my
students and I made it very obvious when
I was explaining the question but you
might be able to infer that a
is the center of a circle that creates
this Arc over here right a is the center
if I were to complete this whole circle
out here it would be a bit bigger
obviously all the way out this way then
a would be the center of that Circle
right so how can I use that fact to help
me well if I were to construct onto here
right uh let's use this one from a up to
C
you can see that because B and C are
both on the circumference of this
incomplete Circle what you've got here
from A to B and then a to c these links
are related they're both going from the
center to the circumference in other
words they're both radii of that full
circle so what I can say is if this
length down here is 25 millimeters then
so is this one right but I can just go
further with that logic not only can I
use that logic for the circle with
Center a I can use that logic for the
circle with Center B so what that means
is if I were to take this same kind of
shape over here and say from B up to C I
just have this other Circle it's it's
this one over here which has a center at
B but I've again got to radii in this
case it's B to a and then B to C it's
this time it's a and C that are on the
circumference so therefore
I've got another equal length there it's
also 25 millimeters so what I've created
here is not just any triangle this is an
equilateral triangle and that's
significant because it tells me the
angle here in the corner just like all
of the lengths in an equilateral
triangle are the same I mean that's what
equilateral means equal length you've
also got equal angles because in any
triangle equal angles are opposite equal
sides same with isosceles as well so
therefore what you've got here with this
60 degrees enables you to work out
number one when it comes to area what is
the area of this if you have a look here
I've just kind of drawn this earlier to
make it easier what is the area of this
this shape here that I've shaded this is
a sector so it's like a slice of pie or
a slice of pizza the particular
proportion of the circle it is is it's
60 don't delete it that's not helpful
it's 60 degrees out of the whole
Revolution which is 300 and 60 degrees
so therefore this sector is exactly
one-sixth of the circle that it comes
from and I'm also going to use that fact
for when I'm working out the uh the the
length of the arc as well BC and of
course um AC is is the same Arc just
flipped around okay
now the other thing that you need to
know to work out this area is that well
this sector is is not the whole area
obviously I've got this weird sliver
over here and then you might say well
what is that sliver over there it's
called a segment by the way how am I
supposed to work out what this part in
here is equal to I don't have a formula
for it unlike what I have for the
um area of a circle and then I can just
slice into equal pieces this is not
um you know there's no formula for the
equal amount there at least not one that
students have learned by this time in
the course I think they were probably
around year eight students and it might
be only around year 11 actually but they
end up to sort of deriving a formula for
this as it were you don't need a formula
you just need to have a careful think
about the shapes that are composed
together and that's the whole point of
this entire exercise right what I want
you to notice is if you were to take
uh this sector here right noticing that
this sector here is identical to and
remember this is from the center of a
it's identical to the other sector that
has a center from B if I were to just go
up and do the curve on that side right
now if you were to put those two sectors
one on top of the other keep in mind
they are actually the same sector I want
you to see what you actually get
here it is this is the one um the purple
one it has a center a and then the green
one has a center at B now if you were to
take these two sectors and and overlap
them right what you can see is that
there's this area that gets counted
twice right it is this one in here can
you see that this is a triangle that
kind of gets double counted because it
is shaded both purple and green so in
order to work out what this composite
area is all I need to do is take that
original sector this one up here in
purple double it that'll give me the
purple one and the green but then I need
to take away much like I did in this
question I need to remove the part that
has that is extra that's been in this
case double counted which is the
triangle that I've just put in Orange
here okay and that triangle is very very
similar to the one that we did
in the previous question because it is
equilateral just like this one and you
can use those facts to combine it with
Pythagoras and work that out okay so
that's basically the map through that's
that's I think the hard part um being
able to reason through and see what
shapes are actually interacting with
each other but now let's actually go
ahead and and do the calculations okay
so for starters let's begin with area
the area of this sector as I mentioned
it before it is uh one-sixth of the
circle that it belongs to so I'll go 1 6
times pi r squared now in this case
you're just going to be careful what is
the radius and the radius is just the 25
that stated there because remember this
this Center a creates a bigger Circle
and by definition a radius is from the
center to the circumference so the 25
has already been given to you
so that's going to be 25 squared I
happen to know that 25 times 25 is 625
so for now I'll just leave those and
that answer exact okay that's one sector
then I need to work out with the area of
that double counted triangle is the one
that's got these horizontal Orange Lines
on it right so therefore I'm just going
to call this area of triangle a b c and
what you're going to get is it's going
to be
um number one it's half times the base
which in this case is 25 and then I have
to work out the height now I work this
out in exactly the same way that I
worked out this one the one where I
caught my error there's going to be a
subtraction because the height here just
like before it's not the hypotenuse
right
so therefore what I'm going to get here
is the hypotenuse is loan if you want to
fill this in for you if you like let me
put this in here so here's the right
angle the hypotenuse is known it's 25
I've got this length down here it's 12.5
and this is the unknown the height right
so the height is what I need for the
area calculation so it's going to be 25
squared take away 12.5 squared
I've got 12.5 on the outside because
that's I just did half of 25 I do not
know what this thing is underneath the
square root so let's go ahead and work
it out 12.5
squid
okay so that's going to be the square
root of
468.75 obviously I can approximate that
but I might as well wait until I
actually do the full calculation so what
I've got here is the total area
and as I mentioned before what I'm going
to do is Count both sectors that
accounts for both of the curvy Parts but
then I need to subtract the triangle so
I might as well say that 2 times the
area of the sector
take away the area of the triangle so
what have I got here see
punch it in correctly
383. there we go Square millimeters all
right let me review what was I saying so
I'm gonna my sense check here is to
check this triangle right because this
triangle as I mentioned before composes
most of the area so I'm pretty confident
in this calculation here so if I just
say what is 12.5
take a times the square root of
468.75 what's that going to be equal to
this by itself is just
270.63 millimeters squared right so you
can see we're in the ballpark 270 383
and does it make sense that these extra
bits would be about 110 that does seem
pretty reasonable to me because you can
see the relative size compared to the
original triangle so I'm pretty content
with that answer
and now All That Remains is to actually
go to the perimeter now thankfully the
perimeter is simpler we don't have to
worry about Pythagoras or things like
that let's switch over the color
so what I want to do is for starters I
should work out what the arcs are so Arc
let's do that a bit more neatly Arc uh
AC for example as mentioned before this
is 1 6 of the circumference so the
circumference is I've got the radius
here instead of the diameter so I'm
going to use the 2 pi r form of the
formula
so that's going to be 25 Pi on 3 and I'm
going to double that because you can see
I've got Arc AC and then I've also got
Arc BC which is identical then I just
need to add that to 25 so I'm pretty
content that we can do that in one Fell
Swoop total perimeter
[Applause]
is equal to double the arc
plus a b which is the 25 across the
bottom so I'm going to get let's
calculate what 50 Pi on 3 is that's the
arc twice plus the 25 which I got along
the bottom and that's
77.36 millimeters now again it's
important to do a sense check here and
this is one of the reasons why the
approximation is more helpful sometimes
than the exact answer even if the exact
answer is more precise that 25 there
right at 25 if I multiplied it by 3 to
just get a triangle I'd get 75
millimeters right so if I just had that
triangle but then I voted out a little
bit and that gives you this additional
curve you can see that's what accounts
for that small additional
um factor to the perimeter right it
makes it a little bit longer but not by
much because you can see this Arc AC is
very very similar to the in this case
it's a chord AC or that link that
interval ac they cover the same distance
just over a little longer it's the
scenic route as it were
so I hope you found that helpful even
with me finding and tracking down a few
of the mistakes in there myself
questions like this where you have a
look at
um you know trying to work through all
the composite figures and what have you
I think are less about the measurement
and more about how you think about the
relationships the spatial relationships
between the shapes that are involved
particularly when we're having a look at
this last one here it isn't obvious at
all and even after you do it you think
is that is that correct and a sense
check is the really the only thing that
tells you that confers to you yes I'm on
the right track so go ahead have a go at
making some questions of your own and
see if you can create some interesting
shapes that end up being interesting to
solve